the lay ohio pen show
[Music]
sponsored by step finance
your go to d5 portfolio manager on
solana
luno if you're just getting into bitcoin
it's the perfect place to start
[Music]
hey guys and welcome back to another
episode of the lehigh plan show today is
going to be so much fun because i'm
bringing a guest on who i think we agree
um on a lot of different issues in the
world right now and um i'm pretty sure
he can articulate many of these points
better than i can so i'm really excited
to chat to him but before i bring him on
as usual this is powered by the vc firm
icon plus capital and is sponsored by
blockfi i've left a link in the
description and in the comments um if
you want to check them out they offer
really cool interest rates i think
around 11
um or something like that on your
stablecoin so it is pretty cool all
right so let's get into this joining me
today is the host of the mark moss show
on iheartradio i think that kind of
gives it away it is um he's a freedom
maximalist and the person who's on a big
mission to wake people up
what's up
that's right you got that right thanks
uh thanks so much for having me it's a
pleasure to be here i'm uh
happy to dig in
yeah i want to go for this um i'm not
going i'm not going to do any background
stuff i want to go straight into this
but is that right in saying you're here
to wake people up
and that's what i'm trying that's what
i'm trying to do you know i think um the
way that i see the world is that uh
i think we're kind of in world war three
and it's the governments versus the
people and i think really it's not a war
people are afraid of you know going to
nuclear war right now i i don't think
that's you know i think that's not very
probable i think there's a low
probability that happens i think the
real war is over information
and money war it's over information and
money and uh i made a comment that kind
of turned into a meme and i said we have
memes and we have bitcoin and they got
nothing right so we have we have the
tools that we need to win but it's
really it's a war of information and i
think we see this um
more now than ever before and so just
like the printing press changed things
in the 1500s the internet is changing
things today and so they've lost the
narrative they lost their grip
alternative news like what you're doing
like what i do has taken off obviously
joe rogan tucker carlson are smashing
whatever they control and so they've
lost their grip on information and
they're trying to get back that we can
dig into that more
but
i think it's a race and the race is can
we wake enough people up
before
they can reach their end goal
and that's right so i'm trying to wake
as many people up as i can yeah yeah no
this is great there's so much to get
into um let's just go for it okay so
we're talking about let's start with
bitcoin um and we'll start with canada
so i think the narrative um surrounding
bitcoin is slightly changing um you know
at the beginning of covid i shouldn't
even say that because of basketball and
stuff at the beginning of you know what
yeah
yeah watch out um yes at the beginning
of covered um you know we were really
pushing that safe haven asset right
especially because we saw the markets
crash bitcoin came fighting back but now
we're sort of seeing the whole you know
it's a hedge against tyranny
the idea that it's just humanitarian
money i think we saw even with ukraine
around 4.4 million dollars in bitcoin
being donated um you know people being
able to um use bitcoin you know despite
the canada freezing their bank accounts
so how is this going to help with mass
adoption bitcoin as this humanitarian um
type of money and i guess the whole um
everything that's going on in the world
right now is kind of helping sell it
yeah well um humans are very simple at
their core right they were really
motivated by two things so humans want
to rush towards pleasure or they want to
run from pain and so we have those are
the two main it's the character of the
stick those are two main things that
drive us as humans and so when uh you
know the crypto markets are going
parabolic it's sucking everybody in i
want to get rich i want to get rich
everyone's making money but me and it
starts sucking people up and the and the
more that more people sucked in the more
it goes up and it turns into this
parabolic run and that but then when the
blow off top happens and it starts
crashing then people run from the pain
and they want to sell right that's why
it's very volatile at the top but also
back to the kind of point that you're
making
is that we also again motivated by pain
so for example i believe in going to the
chiropractor i believe in having a solid
base and if my spine's in in proper
position the rest of my body works right
um and i've gone for most of my life and
i really believe in it but
i don't typically go anymore until i'm
in pain the pain has to motivate me and
so the reason why i say that is back to
bitcoin so if we look at you know parts
of the world in africa central america
where they have serious problems they've
moved on to bitcoin first because their
pain is high enough so
um what we've seen in obviously our you
know venezuela 2500 inflation or lebanon
98 inflation they switched out their
currency for them the pain is so high
they're moving to bitcoin as fast as
they possibly can in the united states
in canada western europe they don't
really have that pain they've been
mostly motivated by pleasure i heard i
can get rich if i buy bitcoin or now
chase a cryptocurrency i called bitcoin
the great bait and switch so it sucks
you in to make money and then you stay
for the freedom aspect but what we're
seeing now
is the entire world has woken up to the
actual pain so the pain like i said in
argentina venezuela lebanon they see
that but in the u.s and canada we're
like uh what do we need that for like
our money's like pretty good yeah i mean
sure you know it's the the fed created
35 more money we had 35 inflation but
you know that's not as bad as 2500
inflation right so the pain wasn't high
enough for most people but all of a
sudden in the last whatever two to three
weeks in canada we just saw that
your money isn't safe your money isn't
your money so the truckers the people
that donated the truckers got their
money frozen and then what the world
just saw
there's three global superpowers in the
world u.s china and russia three global
superpowers with nukes
russia being one of them
and their bank accounts just got seized
and it was one thing if it was the
truckers in canada but now a sovereign
nation with nukes and so the world just
realized really fast that your money is
not safe
so
the weird part of all of this is we're
kind of seeing it on both sides right so
we're seeing money being donated to the
canadians to fight the government we're
seeing money being donated to ukrainians
to fight the government but then there's
also the question you know is russia
going to start adopting bitcoin or any
other cryptocurrencies um to circumvent
sanctions i know elizabeth warren was
saying something i didn't even read it i
don't listen to her stuff but i know she
was saying and if you say you know
actually i did read it um she said
something like uh this is why we need
more regulation on digital assets or
something like that yeah so how do we
explain to people
that this
as much as it's for you it's also for
your enemies
but it's still important like how do we
because my concern is we're gonna you
know if russia do start to
circumvent sanctions using crypto they
could use any i don't really know um
maybe they'll use bitcoin but i worry
that we could end up being kind of like
a client in the environmental climate
change issue that we saw with bitcoin
and elon musk you know last year
well a couple things i'd say first off i
think trying to discuss it at that level
is at the wrong level and so it's really
much deeper problem so like um really
it's the money system that got us to
this point that we're at today so now oh
should should we ban bitcoin because
russia wants to use it i mean that's the
conversation like um at a two micro
level we kind of have to zoom out that's
one thing i'd say the other thing that i
would say about that is that um to your
point someone might say they're our
enemy and they're using it so we need to
ban that but everyone's an enemy of
somebody the world's never been more
divided and so whether you're left or
right or red or blue or whatever right
somebody's on the other side of that and
so you're always gonna be someone's
enemy so you have to think about that
i'm always gonna opt for the side of
freedom as you said freedom maximalist
and so
a couple things i would say um one is
that um sanctions right that's the tool
the us dollar has been weaponized it
wasn't just elizabeth warren as a matter
of fact brad sherman from california has
been on the news for a couple of years
now saying that cryptocurrencies
undermines the u.s dollar and it
undermines the us's ability to put
sanctions on nations like iran he
actually said that and so if on iran
listening to that i'm like oh
so it takes away their ability to
sanction us maybe we should use that
um and so freedom is messy
for you to have the freedom to say what
you want to say you might say things i
don't like sometimes
but that's just the way it works and so
the freedom to transact
i understand what you're saying uh i
think um
yeah i don't know i don't know if i
answered that
no it's fine i i think we are going to
get into like a little bit of a war over
it like i really do i think it's going
to be the same kind of freedom of speech
wall because you and i both understand
that freedom is messy and in order for
freedom to um prevail you are allowed to
offend me and i can cry over it but like
i i still i still defend your right to
say it um but i'm concerned that we're
gonna get into this kind of tug of war
with bitcoin well we absolutely are
because what's happening is um
sanctions right so we're
we're either limiting what people can do
in the financial system or in the case
with russia potentially moving them out
of the financial system altogether
so if we kick
russia out of the swift system out of
the banking system or limit their
ability to even use it for that matter
then what do they do they do they just
go into a hole and just die
no they just figure out how to work
around it so if they really cared about
keeping the russia in then they would
want to have them inclusive if they kick
them out all they're doing is forcing
them to use something different same as
the canadians so the canadians they were
kicked out their bank accounts were
frozen et cetera i know some of them
started coming back online but
now all those people have to find a way
to survive without the financial system
if you and i were having a party or
let's say i was having a party
and i said hey you're being too noisy
you got to go outside and hey you're
doing this you go outside and you go
outside you go outside
next thing you know i'm the only one
left at the party and everybody else
went and started their own party and i
have no control over that party
because i kicked them out of my party
and so that's kind of what's happening
with the financial system in canada
kicking them out of the finance system
russia kicking them out of the financial
system they have no other choice but to
find another way now
bitcoin sure cryptocurrencies okay uh
they just made a 650 billion dollar deal
with china to sell them natural gas in
euros so should we outlaw euros as well
maybe
right and so like where does this go
right
if you don't use the money that we say
that we have complete control and we
kick you out of then you can't use
anything else
like how does that even make any sense
okay we're going to get to the whole
complete control thing remind me i need
i need to we can talk about that yeah
complete control um and then the endgame
and all that stuff but something i've
actually been really curious about and
i'd like to get your opinion on is you
know if we all do
adopt this new system right to fight
tyranny and you know i'm i'm ready to do
it um
we're all adopting it what seriously
though like what happens if the internet
shuts off yeah
so that's a that's a that's a big
question that's asked all the time um i
think it's a little ridiculous and so
what i would say to that is i don't
think in things in terms of absolutes
there is no absolutes in life i think of
things in terms of probabilities
aliens could come destroy the world
tomorrow the probability of that
happening is
barely above zero right
maybe there's it's not zero any anything
can happen right um so will what happens
if the internet turns off so like the
entire world's internet goes off forever
and never comes back
the probability of that happening is
almost zero
so the internet is a layer and so you
have about seven layers it starts with
the wires the fibers in the ground then
it goes up to the switches and then it
goes into like the tcp protocols the ip
addresses the the dns domain name
servers and then the isps internet
service providers um so in china they
have the great firewall of china right
so there's no google facebook none of
that's allowed in china
but people use vpns and they get around
that
um they can shut off the okay so they
that's the isp they write around that we
can use tor well let's say that they
stopped that and now the dns doesn't
work anymore well if we still have the
ip address we can just go directly to
the website the internet is pretty
censorship resistant we know this
because
using bittorrent i can still download
music and movies they've never been able
to stop that so
the the probability of the entire
world's internet going down and never
coming back is
barely above zero um they would be
cutting off their own communication now
let's say that it happens more regional
okay so for example um before the
pandemic broke out hong kong was being
taken over by china and there was
massive protests going on um
of course the world didn't come out to
protect democracy in hong kong like they
are in ukraine but that's a whole other
story but um when that was happening um
china was shutting down all the
communications in hong kong so they
couldn't organize so phones and internet
were taken down to your point in that in
that area
but what they did was
um on their phones they use something
called mesh networks and a mesh network
allows me to build my own network and so
everybody that has this mesh network on
their phone we create our own network
and they can't stop that they can't shut
that down and so in hong kong they're
using these mesh networks and they're
still using that to connect to to uh
share information and
we can even send bitcoin over a mesh
network
that's really interesting um because i
do that is one of the things that does
just concern me because i know when we
talk about low probabilities we'd also
had said you know there's a low
probability that the world would shut
down for two years we'd sort of think
you know why would they do that that
would you know screw themselves
um
that's kind of my my concern
you know what i mean yeah but like i
said they they'd literally have to rip
the wires out right ground and okay
great so you ripped wires out of the
ground now we have now we have
satellites
yeah no i know i'm with you um you know
we saw what elon musk did recently for
ukraine which was really interesting um
but it's interesting because we've just
gone from
well the world has gone from blm to
covid
and it's gone from covid
like straight to a war
now i want to just preface my next
question by saying all war is bad
because apparently you need to make that
clear people don't think that people are
human enough to you know hate war um or
as bad all killings all over the world
are bad murders are bad i don't support
any kind of war um you know but my my
question is
it just seems like the timing just seems
off and then it's not just the timing
it's also the um i need to think about
the way that i say this um it's also the
the priority that it's getting right
and you know we saw just to say we saw
you know chamath a few months ago sort
of talk about how what's happening in
china um is sort of you know below his
line of caring
so why is this not below everybody's
line of caring
well
we think
whatever they want us to think
whatever gets the news whatever gets 24
7 rotation whatever fills up our feeds
that's what we think about whatever they
want us to think about
um back to your point though all war is
bad sure you know ten commandments thou
shalt not kill i believe that and um
what's crazy about war is that um you
know people in the u.s don't hate the
people in russia people in russia don't
hate the people in ukraine it's the
governments that me who do right and so
um that people have to go to war and
kill each other it's ridiculous the
people in ukraine don't hate the people
in uh in russia there was a there was a
famous story and uh i think it was world
war ii and it might have been between
the uk uh i forget the details but they
were in these trenches for days or weeks
and and there was like this no this zone
that nobody could pass and they were
just basically stuck there and it was
like christmas eve
and there was like a ceasefire and the
soldiers like came out and started
playing some music and put some trees
out and next thing you know all the
soldiers from both sides who had been
there for weeks or months hold up trying
to kill each other were out celebrating
together right we're all people we don't
hate people in russia ukraine whatever
it's the leaders that's the problem that
we need to talk about
um so i agree with you war is bad um
but um i think
it's in my opinion so from a zoomed out
lens this isn't really like a random or
a black swan so you talked about how did
it go from uh one narrative to the next
and so fast well i think if you zoom out
and you look at things a little bit
differently from a bigger lens maybe
they become a little bit more clear so
what do i mean by that well um i've been
doing a lot of work into these um like
three revolutionary cycles that are
converging right now so um history
although it progresses like
exponentially it also repeats over and
over and over so we have these these
cycles that continue and the reason why
is because as humans we have that so
um there's a political cycle a 250 year
cycle there's a technological cycle that
operates on a 50-year timeframe and a
financial revolution cycle on an 80 year
so an 80 a 50 and a 250 but all three
are converging right now which i believe
explains why the world has gone
completely mad and why it's moving as
fast as it are as it is right now so uh
there's a famous quote from vladimir
lenin from russia and he says that
there's decades where nothing seems to
happen and then there's days where
decades seem to happen and that's
exactly kind of where we're at right now
right we just went from this whole
covered war for two years and now all of
a sudden forget no one even knows about
that anymore kind of a thing um and so
this days or decades are happening uh
but this kind of fits into you i'm sure
you've heard about the fourth tourney
which is an 80-year cycle so um you've
never heard about the book the fourth
turning no
everybody in bitcoin's heard about the
four tournaments
uh you've probably you've probably heard
this so it's an 80-year cycle it's
broken up by four 20-year cycles
and it's something called generational
theory so you've probably heard that
hard times create strong men oh
yeah yeah yeah i have yeah yeah so hard
times great strong men strong men create
good times good times create weak men
weak men create bad times or hard times
and then the hard times create strong
men again so it's like this cycle and
it's kind of this generational theory
and part of it's like my grandfather was
a farmer in iowa and i mean to to live
on the farm and work on farm is
ridiculous hard work people have this
romantic vision of it it's not easy
my father grew up on the farm
but then left the farm to start a
business and he was the hardest worker
i've ever met not but not as hard as my
grandfather my dad made me go work with
him when i was a kid and i hated him for
it and i'm an extremely hard worker
because of that but i'm not near as a
hard worker as i as my dad and my kids i
can't even get them to clear the table
right it's like four generations um so
that's kind of how it works but
what's interesting is on these 80-year
cycles about every 84 years there's a
populist uprising or a regime change so
84 years ago was the end of world war ii
that was hitler mussolini in the u.s we
had fdr's new deal
84 years before that karl marx wrote the
communist manifesto which led to the
european spring which is the largest
revolution in history
three times 84 equals 252. so every 250
years there's a revolution cycle so 250
years ago was the american revolution
the french revolution 250 years before
that was the protestant reformation so
about every 250 years there's this
revolution that happens and of course
this is the cycle that we're in right
now so while a lot of people are like
well mark this uh this is a black swan
event who would have ever predicted that
a virus would come and the whole world
would lock down to the point you made
earlier
well history would have predicted that
as a matter of fact it tells us right
now we're in a regime change cycle and a
revolution cycle and it's happening
right now and as we just kind of talked
about in hong kong
or and actually before the pandemic
broke out there was ten countries with
over one million people each
protesting
wow that was before the pandemic so this
this is not about a pandemic this is not
about some black swan virus this is
about
a revolution and what is the revolution
the revolution is peak centralization
and the world is pushing back on peak
centralization to move into
decentralization so 250 years ago the
american french revolution the americans
were pushing back on the centralization
of the monarchy
and we created a decentralized
government the united states is a
republic 50 independent states
it wasn't 50 at the time uh 250 years
before that was the protestant
reformation which at the time the church
in the state had a complete monopoly on
control
the printing press as i mentioned
earlier
decentralized the information and when
people were able to read that they said
wait a minute you've been lying to us
all this time we don't need you and it
moved into a decentralized thing so
right now we're at peak centralization
it's easy to see world economic forum
world health organization world trade
organization i you know imf u.n et
cetera we're at peak centralization but
the world is pushing back we don't want
that and that's why there's um eruptions
all over the world right now if that
makes sense
it does um i have
several questions okay so the idea of um
peak centralization
so okay so my most basic oh my gosh well
okay if it's a basic question or not but
okay let's go for it so peak
centralization
um
to what extent is this revolution then
of decentralization going to win because
i think that um we're seeing a lot of
the infrastructure um already be put in
place um you know imagine noise who i
absolutely love um talks about um the uh
the the vax passports and how that's
needed for um cbdc's so the
infrastructure is there and the whole
social credit system and stuff like that
um and you know it's very clear it's
very clear in my opinion that
those in power have a huge amount of
control over the narrative the way we
can just go from two years you can go
for not just two years but you can go
from an actual protest
in canada where people are literally
imprisoned in their own country they
can't leave they don't have a medical
cert met a certain kind of medical
uh procedure happened to them to a war
that nobody is that nobody's talking
about what just happened the fact that
we can do that so quickly just shows how
much um power these people the elite
have over what's happening and they're
being honest about it
so the first question is to what extent
are we going to win this this revolution
in terms of decentralization yeah that's
a that's a great question
first i'm going to answer it and then
i'm going to go back and explain it so
we can win all right okay we we will win
we do win
history tells us that now um we'll go
back and set that up um so um kind of
through the point that you're making
you're absolutely right
and that is uh about the social credit
score system the cbdc's et cetera um and
and about the narrative so uh what do i
mean by that back to the 1500s right the
church had a complete monopoly on
information and they um told people that
you had to buy your salvation and you
had to do these things for the church
and all these things but when people got
the information they said wait a minute
you're lying to us this is not how it
goes and the church anyone who would
read that or speak out on it was labeled
a heretic you probably heard that word
heresy and they were they were killed
right
but it didn't matter
it didn't matter how many
how hard they tried to squeeze
um it didn't matter how many people they
killed
the information was out the technology
changes they lost their grip today we're
in the same situation where they've
realized
this peak centralization wf imf etc
they've realized that they have lost the
narrative to your point um like i said
tucker carlson um joe rogan they're
getting you know a hundred times more
views than any other of their of their
sources and just like the printing press
the internet has disrupted their grip
now i think what they've done is they've
realized like shoot we're losing this we
need to crack down now we need to get
this final piece put in place or we're
going to lose all control and we're
going to kill people to do it now not
killing people like in the process
reformation but killing people as far as
de-platforming them assassinating their
character you know cancel culture et
cetera
um and so i think what we're seeing is
that's that was the race that i was
alluding to the race is can they install
a social credit score system in place
which would include a cbdc right to
include a global id
um can they install that before enough
people wake up
and push back and overthrow that and so
that's really the race um i made the
statement that we win and i'll kind of
explain that
but they they are trying their best to
control the nerve like i said we think
whatever they want us to think if they
want us to think that covet's the big
thing it is if they want us to think
that canada is and now it's ukraine is
the thing
but really it's the race to get that and
so
um i was thinking that this was all
coming to a head remember these three
cycles are converging i haven't talked
about the other two the technological
and the financial um but it's all coming
to a head right around 2025 and i was
think it's really like you know 2024 to
2026 right
and so i was thinking that's the time
now what's interesting about that is
that the central bank digital currencies
are not ready right so china has rolled
theirs out china's rollers out but the
u.s fed doesn't have theirs the ecb
doesn't have theirs yet but we know that
the fed's working on it pretty fast
right we know that they've been working
out for about a year and a half we know
that they just opened it up to comments
about like a month ago so it's coming
along pretty quick i'm guessing there's
another 12 to 24 months before it's
ready to roll out and this whole social
credit score system doesn't really work
until they get that cbd see it's kind of
that last piece they need in there
and so i think if you understand that or
i should not understand it but maybe
kind of see what i'm see what i'm going
with this that's the goal if i was like
herding cattle or sheep across the
countryside for example my goal is to
move these sheep across the countryside
and get them into a pen over here at the
end but you know i have a lot of land to
cover and so i have to kind of push him
here and i have to kind of push him here
and i have to kind of push him here and
so over here is the push from the
virus and over here is the push from the
protest and over here is the push on the
cyber pandemic right and each one of
these is pushing us to the ultimate goal
which is the social credit score system
so none of these pieces the the past the
vaccine passport none of those pieces
are
the ultimate goal it's one push to get
us to the ultimate goal which is the
social credit score system and it all
hinges on that cbdc
without freedom to transact
there is no freedom period
so i have the i have the right in the
united states i have the freedom the
first amendment guarantees me the right
to assemble to go protest or whatever
well if i don't have money to put gas in
my car to drive to the assembly or buy a
bus ticket to go simply i have no
freedom i have freedom of speech well if
i have no money to buy a computer to
post online or print a pamphlet or build
a website i have no freedom of speech i
have the freedom of religion well if my
church can't afford to pay a payment on
a building or can't pay their staff
there's no freedom of religion so there
is no freedom without the freedom of
payments
and that's what the cbd that you know
that's where they come in
if that makes sense and so i think what
they've realized over the last two years
they're losing their grip
and they had to do something they needed
to really escalate this speed this up to
try to hang onto that grip the problem
is the more they squeeze the more people
push back newton's third law says in
physics is each force has an equal and
opposite reaction so the more they
squeeze the more people push back but
the more people push back the more they
squeeze the more they squeeze more
people push back and now we're at this
situation where it's escalated to the
point where they're literally kicking
people out of the financial system and
forcing people to go build a parallel
society which is a whole other topic
but the
the thing with russia does confuse me
because it's not as if you know russia
is this noble country like they're doing
some bad things right like i've seen
their bombs going off um in ukraine like
that's obvious um but what i don't
understand is how that comes into play
with
everything that's going on
um i'm not saying it's not real like
let's just be clear
obviously not saying that's not real um
but but there's something going on
like it's strange yeah that we've just
gone from one narrative to another and
also sorry just to say as well and also
just like the amount like i'm saying
earlier the amount of priority um
ukraine is getting in the media
yeah it's very interesting um it's it's
a weird time where we don't know what to
believe anymore right we know that our
governments have lied to us non-stop
they've they've admitted that they've
lied to us they've admitted that they've
run psyops psychological operations
against us um we see our media using
techniques like um nlp neuro-linguistic
programming against us um and so we
that now it's like we don't know who to
trust us like that boy who cried wolf
and we just can't trust them anymore and
so it's very difficult to know what's
going on yeah again i think if you zoom
out um and look at really this peak
centralization i think that the world
has been taken over by bankers so if you
had like a business org chart the way
that the world was formed at the very
top sits the bis the bank of
international settlements they're at the
top of the org chart and then below that
then you have the um
the world economic forum and you have
the imf and these are like the policy
makers so they set these policies and
they push them down below that you have
the governments and those are the policy
enforcers then you have the media that
distribute those policies the
information and then we have us the
people at the bottom and so um when you
look at that and what's the goal here
well the big goal if they want to get
the whole world into this type of a
system with peak centralization is they
have to bring down unfortunately and i
hate to admit this because i'm an
american but they have to bring down
america
america is the shining example on the
hill of freedom it's the the the
greatest experiment that's ever been
done has brought more people out of out
of poverty than any experiment in the
history of the world and we're the only
nation in the world that has guns and so
the united america america has to fall
and we want to transfer the power from
the west which is america western europe
canada et cetera and it has to transfer
from the west to the east
and so if you if you would agree with
that or maybe at least kind of see what
that picture may look like then maybe it
brings a little bit of clarity to this
war with russia
because really what's the objective here
right the objective is to bring the us
down and push power to the east so we
can install a social credit corps system
so what's going on with the war and
again i'm not saying this is fake um
there are i believe there are real bombs
being dropped in ukraine and i do
believe people are really dying um
but is it part of the narrative maybe
maybe not um i don't i don't uh and just
to be clear i don't view this as like
some conspiracy where uh five people in
a room have kept power over the world
for the last 500 years
i look at it more like
if you see a flock of birds flying
around
and they all kind of keep this formation
as they're flying they didn't sit on the
ground and say hey larry over there you
take the left corner and bob you go over
there on the right like they didn't plan
it out they just they happen to just
kind of move together and so that's kind
of the way that i see it this isn't like
some like five people in a room but it's
like they're all working together but if
you if you look at it through that lens
where it's a coup the world's been taken
over by the central bankers
they're all kind of working together in
this power like the policy makers world
economic forum imf et cetera and the and
the goal is then to install the social
credit score system so we have to bring
the us down right have to kind of
destroy that example and then get rid of
guns et cetera and transfer the power to
the east so then now let's look at
russia and ukraine through that lens
okay so then um there's a war with
russia and what's happening well
one
would look like the world still is
fighting for democracy so we don't look
like we've gone too far
two
really what we're doing is destabilizing
the markets and destabilizing the u.s
dollars reserve currency status we're
pushing russia out of either either out
of swift or sanction them very difficult
to force them to find another option
they've now just made deals with china
to give them their energy so what does
china really really need china really
really they don't have resources right
they don't have water they don't have
energy they don't have like coal they
don't have natural gas they don't have
wheat
but they do now they just got all that
from russia
and why did they get it from russia well
because
russia was selling all their energy to
europe
because europe decided not to get theirs
out of the ground anymore and so they
were dependent on russia for it but now
russia just made a deal to give it all
to china
so what happens to europe western europe
and america now
no small kids they fall and what's the
goal but what's the goal
to bring those down so we can transfer
the power so i think if you look at it
from that lens maybe it gets more clear
or maybe i'm just crazy no no no i get
it i get it um my question mike my
question is i often think that um you
know those in charge um of america let's
just look at america for a second
pretty bad people right like it for me i
think i don't just think biden is
senile i think he's bad as well i'm same
with kamila harris um
and so
my confusion would be why would they
want this war if that brings the west
down
so again back to that org chart um the
governments are actually like on the
third row down there
they're like more policy enforcers and
so um an example of this and if you look
back so back to kind of this world
economic forum and and they meet in
davos every year right in davos
switzerland and i think it was 2017 um
donald trump then president donald trump
went to um davos and he gave a speech
and he gave a speech that said um
because at the time the u.s had just
gone into the the paris agreement or the
paris accord i should say and the paris
accord is basically a way that we lay
down our sovereignty and and uh comply
to all these rules that the
i um ipcc or the wf put out and donald
trump went there and he said the us is a
sovereign nation
the us will never lay down our
sovereignty to the rest of the world we
will my job is to look out for the
american people now we're always going
to be willing to work with everybody
else but my job is the america america
first right that's what donald trump ran
on america first make america great
again
he says that the us will never lay down
in sovereignty
at that point at that speech is when the
entire world came after him all guns
blazing
no no no no the u.s needs to take its
place now when donald trump left office
and obama i mean you know biden
took office again what was the very
first thing that they did on day one
they rejoined
rejoined and laid down the america's
sovereignty
to the ngos non-government organizations
um why though like why why why is it so
political like why do you have a
republican doing one thing i know he's
kind of an independent but
and then why why do the democrats do
that i mean
surely it's still america first
regardless of which side you're on well
it's not america first when obama was in
office before no i know but one obama
well when obama was in office before he
was the first president that started
going around and apologizing
for america to the world
obama started apologizing he started um
he brought the you in into the united
states
why to lay down his sovereignty to work
on this globalist agenda right so you're
so you're basically saying that the
democrats or very key people i don't i
don't want to i don't want to say left
or right democrats or republicans okay i
think that the establishment is all in
on this and so again peak peak
centralization we're going into what i'm
calling a blow off top of centralization
and so we've been going we've been we're
in this parabolic run into
centralization and we've all laid down
like the government just take care of
education oh the government just take
care of healthcare oh the government
just take care of everything right and
so we've given the government the nanny
state everything and we're at this blow
off top all the world leaders have
started to buy into these bankers
because how did they do this
it's always about the money right so
it's a coup of the bankers at the top so
you mentioned earlier how did the whole
world lock down at the one time
that's that's easy that's easy i can
explain that in a second tell me yeah
sure easy so they went to each country
and they said hey um you know per our
models the whole world's gonna die and
uh your entire nation's gonna be
completely ravaged and you're gonna go
bankrupt because there's gonna be no
tourism there's gonna be no food it's
gonna be famine and you're all gonna die
but but don't worry don't worry we got
your back what we're gonna do is we're
gonna give you you know 500 billion or
uh 700 billion or 900 million or
whatever the amount is um and and we're
going to help you we're going to give
you all that money so you you don't die
your country's good is that cool okay
but you know
in order to do that and to save the
world we're going to give you that money
but you needed to kind of follow the
protocols that we set
and they all did now we know this to be
true because multiple countries um told
us this so like the president of belarus
the dictator whatever you want to call
him um they he kept turning down their
offers turning down their offers and
finally it was like 900 million
i talked about this on peter mccormick's
podcast they fact checked me in real
time and they found the headline to show
that but multiple nations have have said
that and uh that's what happened they
paid them to do this so how do all these
nations go along with it um they do it
through the money right it's the bankers
that took over the world
this is so fascinating um because
so at first i was i was quite upset to
be i know it sounds kind of ridiculous
but i was quite upset to be watching or
living in a time where we have these
lockdowns like it was very difficult um
but now i'm kind of grateful to be
watching all of this play out like for
me it's insane um and then el salvador
just comes right into this to me el
salvador is like at the center of all of
this um because
because like you said it's all about the
money right
and not all countries are following
what's going on so like dubai had a
little bit of a lockdown but then it
just stopped
so like dubai is very much out of this i
think
you have israel for example who pushed
everything so hard the hardest yeah and
i'm not surprised because for me like
israel was just an explanation of
america
yeah well everyone everything's ending
because of course it's ending but
i mean last night at the state of the
union you know
none of the none of the people on there
were wearing masks and they were all
shaking hands it was just it was just
gone
so since
and of course because the media has got
us all hey look over there
we don't notice that oh wait a minute
you mean the cdc just came out and said
everything that everyone that was d
platform for saying these things they
were right all along but you'd never
admit that because oh look over there by
the way
i'm with you i'm absolutely with you
which is why i just like i refuse to
give
so much attention to things which i
wouldn't usually give attention to um
but just on the previous point about it
all being about the money um el salvador
is clearly not in this in this globalist
you know club right like that is very
exciting and they have a lot of a lot of
they're coming under a lot of fire
because of that
right so let's so let's go into that
because so firstly it's all the about
the money because they're not in that um
you know they can actually promote
healthy eating and healthy this to fight
off the the big bad virus right which
was amazing to see um you know naive
buchely i think he even quoted um biden
this morning or last night um with the
iranian people which was amazing um
so so how much trouble are they gonna be
in and and you know what other countries
aren't part of this big globalist agenda
that can also start raising money
through bitcoin bonds and things like
that yeah well um it
you know again right we've been we've
we've been lied to we know we've been
lied to they've admitted they've lied to
us they've admitted propaganda and
psyops against us they admitted that
they um caused more fear to get people
to comply they've admitted this this is
stuff that's been in writing and been on
interviews and so yeah now we're very
skeptical and now it's hard to believe
anything and so um i try to i try to
always remember that because i don't
want to get too skeptical once you start
believing in conspiracies everything is
a conspiracy and that's not true either
um however that being said
multiple leaders of countries in africa
in uh in haiti they told us that they
were getting bribed to do this
and then multiple ones that didn't go
along with it ended up dead and you know
i'm sure it was all just coincidence but
um it's kind of weird right now as far
back to back to el salvador um
he's coming under a lot of fire a lot of
fire right heavy fire from the imf for
not going along with it and i just saw i
believe yesterday before
there's a new bill that the united
states is trying to put forward um that
that wants to
go after el salvador because of bitcoin
as well because he's
destabilizing the financial system
supposedly what little el salvador tiny
tiny el salvador is stabilizing the yeah
well because uh because of uh you know
terrorism because the people could
terrorists could be running money
through there supposedly um you know
never mind the 80 billion dollars in
weapons or you know 800 million dollars
of weapons that we gave to afghanistan
you know afghanistan has more blackhawk
helicopters than the uk does now never
mind that you know the little bit of
money you run through el salvador could
be the problem but um there's a bill
that the united states is putting
together right now to find ways to go
after el salvador because of bitcoin um
obviously the imf is super mad about it
and the bis they've been making lots of
comments about them destabilizing the
financial system
so
i think it's going to be a big uphill
road for el salvador obviously i'm
rooting for them i've been down there
working with bitcoin beach i love it
what i'd really like to see is we really
need more nations to jump on board with
this so let's hope we're hoping that
this bond sell kicks off gets
oversubscribed
and more nations want to jump into that
i think fidelity put out a report they
said they think that um i think with two
or three more sovereigns will come into
bitcoin this year um and we really need
to see that because if el salvador is
just out there on their own i mean it's
going to be dangerous for him
which do you think will come next i know
panama have introduced um
a similar bill
but i'm not sure yeah um
you know brazil brazil's been talking
about it costa rica's been talking about
it we've seen like uruguay talk talking
about it um
i would say
you know panama has uh
panama is likely you know uh
the the u.s is going to be the last
nation because they have the adult they
have the dollar right the reserve of
course um nations that don't have their
own um that don't have the dollar would
be more likely um specifically ones that
maybe use the dollar right so if on my
own nation with my own currency i might
not want to give up control to print my
own currency but if i'm using the dollar
i have no control over that anyway so
why not just switch over
so i would say it's going to be nations
down there that use dollars already
well the next one i guess is tonga but
that's kind of so tiny it doesn't really
matter uh
not it doesn't matter sorry if you're uh
tongan uh
but uh but yeah maybe panama uh maybe
costa rica maybe brazil probably one of
those nations
any thoughts on turkey
yeah i mean turkey could really use it
for sure lebanon could really use it um
i don't know i don't
i don't i don't have a prediction on
that but but back to the kind of where
we started earlier which is uh when the
pain is high enough remember pleasure
and pain and right now people are being
motivated by pain most likely and so
turkey obviously has massive pain there
um lebanon has massive pain there um i
saw a report that said um in russia i
think a couple days ago bitcoin
transactions were up 250 percent
in a day
because the pain was so high and so yeah
turkey um
any anything that was ukraine i think it
was ukraine
the 200 one i think that was ukraine oh
was it ukraine was it yeah i think it
was bit yeah yeah i thought um either
way one of those um yeah there was an
article that came out said putin said
that if they get hit with sanctions hard
enough they would come after citizens
deposits
so if i was a citizen in russia and i
saw that headline i would probably want
to get my money out of the bank account
right um wait just on that point though
because i saw mastercard and apple
i didn't even read it properly what did
they do because i saw um on the tube
people or we call it the cheaper in
london um you know on the train on the
train people weren't able to use their
apple pay
to get on public transport were you
following what happened no i didn't hear
about that yeah mastercard and apple
have done something i don't know i can
guys you can ask me in the comments
because i'm not gonna quickly surf the
internet but um yeah
mastercard and apple started
stopping yeah go on let's have a look i
can't remember what it was
in in the uk
no no in russia oh in russia
before apple joins other global giants
in exit yeah visa masters block russian
financial institutions
yeah ukraine war long lines for atms in
russia as west restricts cashless
payments by the time you have to wait in
the line it's too late
just for everybody listening
don't wait until you have to wait in
line it's too late but yeah i see visa
mastercard blocked russian banks from
payment networks that's probably what
you're talking about yeah that's it
that's it i mean
why are they doing that
it's so weird why didn't why didn't they
do that in other countries i know we've
gone through this well we're calling out
um there was headlines in the united
states of uh
of of kicking all russian students out
of the country that's awful and
ridiculous and and that and back to my
point um
as an american nobody in america is mad
at russians nobody in russia is probably
mad at people in ukraine it's the
leaders they're the ones causing all
these problems
yeah i'm reading just through some of
the the comments that people are saying
um
and that's why we always say with
bitcoin it's always fix the money
fix the world it's all about fixing the
money and and there's a million reasons
why it all boils down to fixing the
money but these world leaders get all
their power by having a money printer by
controlling the money printer which is
of course what we're seeing play out now
with russia and kicking them out and
sanctions and what if they go to a
different currency and blah blah blah
blah nobody should have that power
so
ted cruz did this speech
um did you see the speech about bitcoin
i saw i saw um a clip i saw some clips
of it i didn't see the whole thing but
yeah it wasn't from the clips i saw it
was good
yeah it was a pretty cool speech um but
he kind of put this real political um
spin on bitcoin and i'd love to hear
your thoughts because before we go into
it my perception right is like the
technology is apolitical but i just
can't be convinced that the
ideology
is apolitical because to me it's just
not
well um one i would say that uh i don't
know if i would necessarily agree with
your statement that he put a very
political spin on it oh he said he said
liberals don't like it he said liberals
don't like it because they can't control
it i think that's yeah no he yeah i was
going to say he did he did say that
but what what the where i see a little
nuance to that is that in the united
states and and probably i'm sure over in
western europe as well um
is now like a
extreme right-wing view
to like want freedom
to me that is not political
i want freedom now
um
donald trump
i mean he's an authoritarian too he
wanted to also tell me what to do no he
didn't want to he didn't want to control
me as much as biden did per se but they
both wanted to tell me what to do
they're both authoritarians i want
freedom i want nobody to tell me what to
do so which party am i for i've always
said that um
i'm for the party that gives me more
freedom and less government which one is
that right i don't know i don't know
which one that is but is that is so so
to that comment that he made um the
liberals or the left or whatever he said
once you restrict your movement restrict
your money restrict your payments one
that's true um and two
um
that the fact that i don't want my money
or my freedom restricted does that mean
that i'm the opposite party
and so that's where i i think like i
said freedom has become like political
but it's not like freedom to transact or
freedom to live my life why is that
political because that's the libertarian
that's the libertarian way right and
libertarian libertarianism is a
political
ideology
yeah i suppose i suppose and i know what
you're saying i mean a lot of people
were mad about ted cruz coming down and
kind of claiming it and part of the
reason why is back to where we started
which is if russia starts to use it
that's a way to demonize it if if ted
cruz and the republicans use it it's a
way to demonize it um the problem is is
that when we saw um when blm and antifa
were burning down the united states
everywhere
i met a lot of blm rallies they were on
stage telling people to get your money
out of the banks and buy bitcoin so blm
and antifa were using it and that's
certainly not republican um so they were
saying to do it um and now the
republicans say this so bitcoin is money
for enemies bitcoin is for everybody and
everybody can benefit from it um it's a
tool right a screwdriver could fix my
car but a screwdriver could also stab
somebody as well right and so it's like
how do you use that tool unfortunately
both sides are going to use that tool
to your point though
and again not to get political but one
side does seem more
[Music]
bent on
really imposing their
regulations on you
and so i guess it does work against that
do you think that in the next election
it's going to become a key
um
like voting point
well it already is so in the united
states we have midterms coming up here
um at the end of the year towards
towards the end of the year in the
united states and we've already seen
many people trying to run on this pro
bitcoin platform so for example
yeah and i don't really like it either
and i'm afraid that people are going to
fall for this um so for example the
mayor in new york kind of ran on this
i'm going to make i'm going to make it
the greatest bitcoin city and then all
suddenly works to shut bitcoin mining
down like wait a minute all these people
that voted for that kind of got the bait
and switch um
in uh in california
i mentioned earlier rep brad sherman
who's been one of the biggest outspoken
critics of bitcoin and cryptocurrencies
because it takes away the us abilities
sanction um there's somebody trying to
run against him erica rhodes i had her
on my radio show and so she's running on
this pro bitcoin platform but then she's
pro welfare and pro ubi
and um
i don't see how those go together
because if i can't create money from
thin air then how can i have a ubi right
so um i would i would tell people to be
aware of this we see in um
in uh in texas right now texas being
this big free state uh kind of the
bitcoin capital of the united states
really the bitcoin capital of the world
probably with mining power anyway uh
governor abbott is facing uh re-election
and there's people challenging him and
they're running on pro bitcoin stuff
like we're gonna make bitcoin legal
tender or we're gonna put laws in to
protect bitcoin so um i do see that now
i guess to your question will we see
that in the next presidential election
it's two years away or
no it's a couple years away uh yeah two
years away um
my prediction says probably no
um two years is a long time right now
um i would say no i think a day is a
long time yeah i mean uh going back to
kind of where i was talking about these
three converging cycles which we didn't
get all the way through but i was saying
it kind of comes to a head around 2025
which is really like 2024 to 2026 kind
of um i think things continue to get
worse for the next couple of years um so
i would guess that uh my prediction says
no i would say that the president
doesn't run on that in two years i'm
just gonna pick you up on that so you
said we didn't get through it i want it
i do want to get through it um so you
predict that it gets worse up until 2025
where we hit a crescendo is that correct
yeah the blow off top that's what i'm
calling yeah the blow off top i like
that okay so we hit the blow off top and
i know that the the the agenda is 2030
that's obviously being sped up to 2025.
um what happens in 2025. well i just
think it's the blow off top right so if
you look at financial markets so if you
look at you know the dot-com boom or
look at you know bitcoin in 2017 et
cetera and you see back to the pleasure
in pain it starts sucking so many people
in that it goes into this parabolic run
now if you study any blow-off tops in
financial markets the reason why it
starts going so high is because it
starts sucking everybody in but you also
know at the very top is when it becomes
the most volatile it's super volatile
top and then it blows off boom right and
crashes back down and i think that's
what we're seeing um from centralization
or socialism or whatever you want to
call it today whereas i kind of made the
case earlier it's like hey government
you just take care of education and day
care and you take care of health care
and you take care of everything we've
just assigned everything to the nanny
state and we're kind of getting this
blow off top and now it's getting very
volatile
right now all across the world people
are pushing back there's protests going
on everywhere
not because of a virus
because of centralization what they're
doing is they're pushing back on
governments restricting their freedom
now the virus was a reason to do that
the money could be a reason or xyz
whatever could be the reason now
potentially war
this is another uh
i'm gonna jump into this rabbit hole
real quick um yeah so i made the case
earlier that this was really a war on
information right that's the war just
like in the 1500s it was a war on
information today it's a warrant
information because they're losing their
grip on the narrative
now if if we're in a war
and we're fighting to get information
out there they're fighting to censor
information so it doesn't get out there
right that would be the battleground so
our job you and i we're creating content
trying to wake people up to this what
are they doing to win the war well they
have to stop people like us from getting
information out there
okay so if you maybe see things through
that lens well how can they do that
how can they stop us from putting
information out there well if you're in
china
under a credit score system you say
something bad about the government they
just disappear you um they can't really
do that in the u.s
they can't do that in the us they can't
do that in the uk in the us we still
have freedom of speech
kind of obviously we can be platformed
so twitter youtube et cetera can kick me
off but other than kicking me off of the
main platforms what can they really do
they don't have a lot of options
unless maybe they do
hmm
so what could be a good reason to have
extra powers to take away people's
ability to say things
well if we look back through history we
can see at least four times
in the united states they've taken
people's ability away to say things so
in the late
1700s the sedition act of 1798's edition
act of 1918
the smith act i think 1940
and basically what happens
is in a time of war
if anybody were to say anything
about the government or the leaders that
could make them look bad or somehow
discredit them
it's punishable up to 20 years in prison
under a war
under a war now we're going to war right
are we really going to war is it a made
for tv war i mean people are really
dying i'm not saying that
but could war be used as a way to win
the war on information
how else can they stop it because they
can't stop the internet right i've
already kind of given that case they
can't stop the internet they can't stop
bittorrent from downloading movies
and they can kick people off of youtube
but they can't stop them putting up on
decentralized platforms like you know
block blockchain like odyssey or
whatever right
but what if they could put them in
prison for 20 years now in china they
can but the u.s they can't well actually
they can they've done it multiple times
in history
under war
hmm that's kind of interesting isn't it
so 20 25 you feel like 25
no i like this no it's cool so 2025 you
feel
we that's the turning point yeah and so
a couple things about that so one we
talked about this political revolution
cycle there's this 250 year which we're
kind of hit that crescendo but then we
have the the technological revolution
cycle so that operates on a 50-year
timeframe it's 40 to 60. just like uh
seasons on a calendar it says spring
starts this day but doesn't mean the
weather changes that exact day um so
technology cycles are like uh 40 to 60
years let's call it 50. now a
technological revolution isn't a new
technology a new technology is like an
iphone that's cool uber that uber's cool
right a technological revolution is
something that changes the course of
humanity there's been five industrial
revolution brought people from farms and
put them into cities and factories um
mass production et cetera um heavy
machinery um two we had steam engines
and railways so all of humanity people
walked and rode horses now we had steam
engines we could move stuff across
continents then we had electricity and
steel all of humanity people had
candlelight and now we had electricity
we also had steel we could build
skyscrapers and bridges
another 50 years after that we had the
age of oil
and automobiles and mass production so
for all of humanity people walking
around horses and now we had cars pretty
cool uh then we had 1971 was the age of
the microprocessor which brought us
telecommunications it brought us the
internet brought us personal computers
brought us mobile phones um everything
that we have today 1971 plus 50 years
puts us at
2021 right about now and the new
technological revolution that we have
today is decentralized technology it's
bitcoin now bitcoin when when
electricity came out what happens as
humans is is uh we can't really imagine
the future we try to take something new
and we try to understand it by comparing
it to something that we know
if you're trying to explain um something
to a blind person be very difficult
because they don't have any reference to
anything right but we try to understand
it by something we know so for example
when electricity came out what is this
thing
well it's kind of like a way to get
light without a candle it's kind of like
a digital candle
well that's stupid what do we need that
for candles have been light for 5 000
years and look how cool it is it's
portable i can carry it around i don't
even need all these wires right well
electricity was
it was a way to get light
but of course it became so much more
right when the internet first came out
what is this thing well it's a way we
can send electronic messages and we have
these like message boards maybe one day
we could even buy stuff online
but of course today we have you know our
cars hooked to something called a cloud
using something called social media to
like navigate us around traffic we
didn't know that um and so bitcoin what
is this decentralized technology well
it's kind of a way to transfer money
store money well it is that yeah it is
that but it's going to be so much more
it will change the course of humanity
and of course
problems are supposed to come to our
solutions are supposed to come to
problems so the problem that we're
having is peak centralization
the problem that we have
is unlimited money printing the problem
that we have is
a set of people that constantly change
the rule on us not ruled by law but
ruled by men the problem that we have is
censorship not just in censorship where
i can't say what i want on youtube but
as i said earlier without the freedom to
transact there is no freedom that's
censorship those are those are problems
that we have so the solutions would be
something with a fixed supply cap
instead of sensual control something
that nobody can control instead of
something that's sensorable it's
something that's censorship resistant
those solutions and so it's interesting
that on a 250-year timeframe we have a
political revolution happening and on a
50-year time frame we have a new
technological revolution that gives us
exactly what we need at the exact same
time which is pretty interesting the
third one is on a 80-year time frame we
have a financial revolution cycle so
about 80 every 80 years the financial
system gets reset 80 years ago
approximately was the bretton woods
agreement the bretton woods agreement
was the entire global financial system
was reset onto a one-world currency a
gold-backed system the dollar of the
reserve other currencies pegged at the
dollar and last year the imf
called for a bretton woods ii
that's their words a bretton woods ii
well what was bretton was one oh that
was a reset of the entire global
financial system onto a one world
currency and now they're calling for
that again
what would the bretton woods 2 be well
um
that's a good question so a lot of
people ask you know will the dollar
remain as the reserve currency uh will
we go back to the gold standard like
peter schiff thinks
would we go to like would we go to a
digital yuan will it be a cbdc like an
imf sdr backed a cbdc but i think
everybody's looking at from the wrong
perspective so they're all looking for a
centralized answer but the future is
decentralized
so
bitcoin has been my reserve asset we see
fortune 500 companies like microstrategy
it's their reserve asset we see nations
like el salvador it's their reserve
asset so the i think the future is much
more decentralized and so everyone's
looking for that centralized answer but
back to kind of this coming to a head in
2025 and so the financial system
um
the the bankers have two tools right
interest rates and monetary supply
interest rates are zero or negative in
most parts of the world so that tool's
gone they have monetary supply but how
much more can they create they've
created over 300 trillion dollars in 50
years already 20 trillion just in the
last two years
they keep printing but inflation's
raging so that tool is pretty much done
if you and i were playing a game
and we're out of moves what do we do
well let's reset the game and play again
that's a bretton woods too
now i've been thinking as i kind of said
earlier that they wanted to keep it
going so a lot of people are like can
the fed keep the markets from crashing
can they can they give us a soft landing
could they taper
and raise rates without crashing the
markets
can they they don't want the markets to
crash right
or maybe they do
that assumes that assumes that you have
a bias that they want to keep the
markets from crashing but what if they
do want them to crash how do you reset
the game how do you move on to a new
system
so all this is converging right now
the the financial game is done they're
out of moves
they're out of moves interest rates are
zero negative they can't keep printing
money inflation's raging high what
happens when inflation rage is high
is revolution
the catalyst for almost every single
revolution is that when people can't eat
and people can't eat when the food's too
expensive um and so that's what they're
facing
technology is here creating a revolution
and now politically we have a revolution
it's all coming together i think it
comes to a head like i said in the next
couple years and the reason why is
because the financial system being reset
all of them being reset and then having
this new system to put us into the
cbd-backed social credit score system um
and they can't wait
if they don't do something now
to put us into a new system that they
can control then they lose everything
and so unfortunately i think we're going
to continue to see more crackdowns we're
probably going to see more regulations
we're going to see more censorship more
de-platforming
you know more sanctions it's going to be
more
but the more that they do the more
people will push back the more people
they kick out of the finance system the
more people go build a parallel system
over here the more people get d
platformed the more people go create
content over here like like alex jones
was the first kind of really big name
guy that got you know killed online
he still gets he still gets millions of
people watching his shows they haven't
been able to stop that so all they did
was force them to go create a system
over here
if you go back and you study the fall of
the ussr the fall of communism back in
the 70s
and 80s
a couple people were very instrumental
in that so solcinicev he wrote the book
uh guleg acropolos
vaclav havel he um he um
he went on to become the pres he got
locked up for i think three years for
his writings but kim became the
president of yugoslavia but they did a
lot of writing it was their writing it
was their information
that led to the fall of communism back
then but one thing that they talk about
is that they started to build parallel
economies and so what do i mean by that
well if i get kicked out of the
financial system
then i have to go use a different form
of money over here i can't fight against
the education system but i can pull my
kids out and i can put them in a
homeschool pod i can't fight against
legacy media
but i can go create my own media company
over here i can't fight against the
financial system but i can just pull my
money out and i can go over here and so
the more they try to restrict the more
people leave the party and by 2025
they're gonna find themselves the only
person at the party
that's amazing um i also am interested
in the fact that the bitcoin halving is
around 2024 oh there's another there's
another good piece
yeah so that's going to be a really
interesting part of the puzzle um you
have a book coming out the uncommunist
manifesto
let's hear about it yeah so alex fetzke
and i got together a couple weeks ago
and locked ourselves in a rental in
airbnb for like five days and and and
wrote a book and basically what we did
is we took the communist manifesto which
i talked about marx wrote now about 175
years ago
and the communist manifesto has
basically gone it's like an ideology
that just won't die um hundreds of
millions of people have died under that
uh socialism regime and and we took that
book which most people haven't read i
actually hadn't read a tale about a year
ago and it's a pamphlet it's a booklet
it's four chapters it's 8 000 words most
people can read in about 45 minutes um
and i would i would i would say that if
most people would read that book they
would never look at marxism or socialism
or communism the same again most people
have this dream idea of what that is but
if they would just read that book so for
example he says
communism can be summed up in one
statement
abolition of private property
that's one statement wow okay so that's
what it stands he says that uh he says
that the bourgeoisie the rich
they only have families they only have
families they only have kids for
exploitation and they only have wives to
have kids
and the bourgeoisie the rich just share
their women so he believes that all
women should just be community property
that's what he says in the book and
women are okay with that like women
should just be community property as a
matter of fact in russia
they actually had that so i think it was
women from like 18 to 25 had to become
community property before they could
settle down
which uh
huxley wrote the book the brave new
world and that's kind of the story in
that book the brave new world um so
anyway if people read that book like if
you read that book you'd probably be
pretty turned off by that right but um
so what we did is we took that book
and we kept the same structure four
chapters um about 8 000 words i think we
came up with 10 000 words so it's quick
it's a less than an hour read um same
structure we took chapter by chapter and
we kind of reframed it and we called it
the uncommunist manifesto and he he
wrote that the struggle which all humans
struggle in life uh find we have you
know finite resources so we all struggle
but he said that the struggle was
between classes the rich and the poor
the bourgeoisie and the proletariat
hitler said that it was a struggle
between races
we reframed it we said that the real
access of struggle is not between
classes or political ideologies the real
access of struggle is between the
individual
versus the collectivist trying to pull
them into groups
and so we reframed it from that
standpoint what we're hoping is that
because it's a quick easy read because
we kept the same format we're hoping
that maybe it could go on to
open people's eyes to what marxism
really is but more importantly show them
a much better system that we can
organize the world around
so you can go to uncommunist.com
and uh we are launching a kickstarter
campaign next week
and then we'll have printed copies at
bitcoin uh at the bitcoin conference
both alex and i are both speaking there
and we'll be doing book signings there
as well
oh i'm so excited to read it um i'm so
excited i think it's going to be great
where can people find out more about you
follow you i know you've obviously um
you're on iheart radio as well
yeah so i have a youtube channel mark
moss and i do like um two teaching
videos a week where i dive into these
types of topics um i have the radio show
on iheartradio you can just search that
mark moss radio um and then um yeah on
twitter i think we're we're streaming
live to twitter so
i'm way too active on twitter i should
probably pull off a little bit one mark
moss on twitter um like i said i'm too
active so if you hit me up with
questions i'll certainly answer them
there and then of course go to check out
uncommunist.com
mark it's been so fascinating i want to
thank you so much for going into so much
detail i've personally learned a lot
i've been reading the comments and
people have found a lot of value in what
you had to say um so thank you so much
for coming on i'm so excited to get your
book and um yeah we'll have to catch up
again sometime i'm going to be in miami
as well so um hopefully we can meet in
person then
ah thanks so much it was a pleasure
being here
absolutely and guys don't forget to
follow mark on twitter and definitely
check out his book and until next time i
will see you all next week thanks for
tuning in
[Applause]
[Music]